millones de hogares y comercios sufrirán
el aumento de los precios de la energía
principalmente en los próximos meses
cuando se espera un muy duro invierno el
regulador británico de la energía
informó que los precios subirán hasta un
tope máximo de 80 por ciento y esto
afectará a 24 millones de familias en
particular las de menores ingresos en
promedio las facturas del gas y la
electricidad aumentarán a un tope de 3
mil
549 libras esterlinas por año esto es un
promedio de 300 libras al mes y esto se
debe principalmente a la guerra en
ucrania y la decisión de rusia de haber
cortado el suministro de gas a europa
para paliar la crisis y el alto costo de
vida el gobierno británico dará a cada
una de las familias aquí en el reino
unido- 400 libras esterlinas para tratar
de aliviar la economía familiar sin
embargo los analistas consideran que es
insuficiente además el alto costo de
vida impulsado por los altos costos de
los energéticos también han aumentado
las tasas de interés y el banco de
inglaterra espera una inflación de
arriba de 13% esta es la más alta de los
últimos 40 años